the coronavirus crisis affects deeply
the European economy and many companies
are temporary weakened by this crisis we
need to take care of them
some sectors are key for security public
health and serenity such as health
medical research or strategic
infrastructure and they deserve special
attention we need to know who invests
from abroad in these companies and for
which purpose this is essentially
important in a time of public health and
economic crisis when we are more
vulnerable and we need to protect our
critical assets and technologies and
this is an European issue we have tools
to do it and I urge member states to use
them today we are issuing guidelines to
help member states screen foreign direct
investment and acquisitions of control
or influence you rules already foresee
screening of foreign investments in
addition many member states have a
national screening mechanism and I
encourage member states to make use of
them to those member states that do not
have such a mechanism I tell them now is
the time to create it in the meantime
you should use all options to protect
critical European companies from foreign
takeovers or influence that could
undermine our security and public order
this should of course be always done in
compliance with EU law and international
obligations I want to be absolutely
clear the European Union is and will
remain open to foreign direct investment
but we need to balance this openness
with a need to preserve our economic
sovereignty